un bar aux airs de musées du PSG pour
les partisans du Paris Saint-Germain le
lieu est idéal pour regarder des parties
quand l'équipe performe à l'étranger ce
soir pour ce match en Italie peu de
pression le club est déjà qualifié pour
participer au 8e de finale de la Ligue
des Champions
[Musique]
mais si Neymar Mbappé il faut dire qu'au
grand désarroi des équipes rivales
certains des meilleurs joueurs au monde
sont dans les rendus PSG
des joueurs jamais dans mon enfance
j'aurais pu rêver ou penser que des
joueurs comme ça viennent dans le club
des talents que les propriétaires du
Paris Saint-Germain ont amplement les
moyens de s'offrir en 2011 un fonds
d'investissement du Qatar est devenu
l'actionnaire majoritaire de la
franchise
[Musique]
une acquisition de 70 millions d'euros
qui auraient notamment été encouragés
par le président de l'époque Nicolas
Sarkozy en tout cas pour le PSG d'avoir
une force économique incommensurable
comparée à ses principaux rivaux et
aussi de s'installer durablement sur la
scène européenne en ayant de forces
investissements
il explique que le Qatar hôte de la
Coupe du Monde a choisi il y a plusieurs
années d'utiliser le soccer comme outil
de diplomatie ça sert en tout cas à
faire exister le
Qatar au niveau international en tout
cas ça participe à cette stratégie entre
le club du Paris Saint-Germain de faire
exister les locataires de l'associer à
une ville mondialement connue qui est
Paris trois ans plus tôt les Émirats
arabes unis avaient déjà acheté le club
Manchester City au Royaume-Uni
d'autres pays du Golfe ont donc adopté
cette stratégie mais le Qatar c'est
particulièrement démarré c'est un tout
petit pays coincé entre deux géants
l'Arabie Saoudite et l'Iran et comme le
Qatar se sent menacé il faut qu'il
existe et ils se sont dit ben en
achetant Neymar Messi on sera très connu
alors on a aussi acheté des rafales des
avions de chasse à la France mais
finalement peut-être que les
footballeurs sont une meilleure
protection pour le pays que les avions
de chasse
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a pas que le Paris Saint-Germain
qui est intéressé des investisseurs du
Qatar cette équipe de la petite ville 2
peines dans l'Est de la Belgique a été
racheté par une fondation du pays du
Golfe il y a maintenant 10 ans sa
mission est bien différente de celle du
grand club parisien de soccer
en 2012 l'équipe de la petite ville de
Pen 20 000 habitants étaient au bord de
la faillite quand ils ont repris le club
le club était mort en était mort et on a
très content est venu reprendre le club
pour
nous donner l'opportunité de de rester
resté compétitif la Fondation sportive
catary espire a vu dans ce rachat
d'occasion de s'enraciner en Europe
c'est parce qu'en Belgique c'est facile
déjà on peut reprendre un club à 100% et
en plus
en Belgique
il y a moyen de laisser jouer beaucoup
des étrangers
pendant plusieurs années les quêtes
belge a recruté de jeunes joueurs
européens mais aussi des sportifs venant
du monde entier parfois des Cathares
futur joueurs de l'équipe nationale du
pays mais aussi de jeunes recrues
africaines que la Fondation aspire
voulait voir grandir sur les terrains
européens ça peut apparaître pour le
clientélisme et le fait de donner les
équipements sportives ou de prendre des
jeunes en stage pour les former les
renvoyer ça crée des liens effectivement
et à travers le sport vous développez
des liens économiques et le sport c'est
très populaire s'il y a un joueur qui
devient une vedette après avoir été
formée au Qatar cela va avoir un effet
positif pour l'image du Qatar dans ce
pays ces efforts pour s'imposer dans
l'univers du soccer ont culminé avec
l'obtention de la Coupe du monde cette
année une immense compétition qui a
attiré l'attention sur l'impact
environnemental des stats climatisés et
les conditions dans lesquelles les
ouvriers les ont construit plusieurs
milliers de travailleurs étrangers
seraient mort au Qatar ces dernières
années selon une enquête du journal
britannique de Guardian je pense que le
Qatar a voulu miser sur la visibilité du
sport mais qui l'ont peut-être pas
calculé au départ que cette visibilité
allait aussi s'exercer sur les aspects
les plus critiques en France l'ambiance
serait bien différente des dernières
coupes du monde dans plusieurs villes
pas d'espace dédié aux partisans ni
d'écran géants pour regarder les matchs
à Bordeaux Lyon Marseille ou Paris ça
s'appelle au boycott au niveau des
villes il est un petit peu hypocrite
surtout vis-à-vis de la ville de Paris
parce que le Qatar outre le PSG a quand
même beaucoup investi dans la ville de
Paris notamment pour sur la question du
tourisme de luxe que pour réaménager les
hôtels donc où il y a il y a quand même
un lien fort entre Qatar et la ville de
Paris
dans la capitale française des intérêts
qatari ont racheté non seulement PSG
mais aussi des hôtels et le magasin bien
connu le printemps à Paris les traces de
la présence du Qatar vendant perdurer
même une fois la Coupe du Monde terminée
il s'est rafale Bouvier au clair
Radio-Canada à Paris